Rachael Dempsey (she/her): hi everyone Thank you so much for joining us today welcome to the RStudio enterprise Community meetup,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): This our finance meetup today i'm Rachael, i'm calling in from our Boston office i'm actually in the RStudio office today i'm joined by my co host dylan lackey from our finance team as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Dylan feel free to say hello and,
Dylan Lackey | RStudio: US yes Hello everyone, I'm based out of the US in Austin Texas,
Dylan Lackey | RStudio: been in open source software for many years, helping folks specialize in making that jump from open source to you know more of a robust enterprise offering actually Rachael is my predecessor so everything I know,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): i've learned from Rachael,
Dylan Lackey | RStudio: so happy to be here and happy to help out,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thanks dylan if you just join now to feel free to introduce yourselves through the chat window and maybe say hello, or where you're calling in from,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Do just want to mention that, if you want to turn on live transcription for the meetup you can do so as well just in the zoom bar below if you press, the more button,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But to go through a brief agenda for today we'll just have some short introductions and then Alan will lead us through their journey,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Towards a reproducible development workflow using a shiny dashboard framework and then we'll have lots of time for questions and open discussion too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And just a reminder to everyone that the meetup is recorded, so it will be shared, to the RStudio YouTube after i'll be sure to put that on linkedin and Twitter and everywhere that I posted about the meetup too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But just wanted to let people know that if you want to ask questions anonymously and not be part of the recording you can do so too i'll put that in the chat window and just a moment here,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But for anyone who is joining, for the first time and now, and if you want to go to the next slide Thank you,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): This is a friendly and open meetup environment for teams to be able to share the work that you're doing within your organization's teach lessons learned and network with each other,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And it really just to allow us all to learn from each other, so thank you all so much for making this a welcoming community to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): really want to create spaces, where everybody can participate, and we can hear from everyone I just really like to reiterate that we love to hear from everyone, no matter your level of experience or the industry that you work in as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): i'll share a few links in the chat if you have any suggestions or want to speak at a future meetup too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But with that Thank you all again so much for joining us today I would love to turn it over to our speaker Alan carlson to Alan is tech lead for the business intelligence team at snap finance,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you, Alan,
Alan Carlson: Thank you Rachel, let me start well, it says that to me share my screen,
Alan Carlson: yeah thanks everyone for for joining today so i'm going to talk about you know building robust modular dashboards with Goldman grandfather packages,
Alan Carlson: We will be going through some just contextual slides make sure we're all the same page, but a bulk of the presentation will actually be building a,
Alan Carlson: Rather dashboard with the package so as far as what we're going to cover today, just a quick introduction about myself so like Rachel mentioned, I work for Sam finances or personal lending for,
Alan Carlson: For customers across the nation, and I am the tech lead on the business intelligence team i've been a developer for four and a half years of the tech lead for the past two,
Alan Carlson: And when I started on the team, there was only me and another developer so we've come a long way from just two of us to now, I believe,
Alan Carlson: Eight of us on on the team my academic background is in business, so I have my undergrad and masters in finance and i'm telling you that because, just as a disclaimer,
Alan Carlson: Since all of my like programming knowledge is job based I don't have a deep understanding of you know, the finer points of programming, so if any of those kind of questions come up i'll do my best to answer them but understand this, that my exact area of expertise,
Alan Carlson: So with that out of the way you know what are we going to talk about so I just want to give context into you know the business challenges that we were facing a couple years ago, you know why we started on this journey,
Alan Carlson: How we tried to answer with golem you know what is gold package, how does it, you know help you know reproduce your dashboards and then traveler is our answer to what gold couldn't do for us at the time,
Alan Carlson: And at that point i'll go into actual like you know coding in our with the the actual package installation and building everything then once that's done we'll switch back to the slides for potential enhancements i've thought about for the future and then finally Q amp a,
Alan Carlson: So with that we'll we'll jump into the the business challenge context so like I mentioned two years ago, there was just two developers right, it was me and another guy and,
Alan Carlson: We had just started working with shiny at that point up until then markdowns were sufficient data polls were sufficient, but the business was growing and they wanted more interactivity and granular looks into their data,
Alan Carlson: And part of this was we had legacy code that was being transferred our department, so the the data science team had built around you know these six dashboards that were pretty complex right they have,
Alan Carlson: You know, six to eight different tabs on a sidebar they all do kind of different,
Alan Carlson: ui layout send it back ends and what we noticed was that these six dashboards are all coated slightly differently right,
Alan Carlson: So the look and feel is pretty similar, but some of them had pure API back ends, some of you sequel instead,
Alan Carlson: They had similar named functions that didn't entirely different purposes on the different dashboards some used, you know select dies input versus picker input,
Alan Carlson: And so the challenge was you spend all this time, focusing on a dashboard, but when you go to the next dashboard you can only port like 40% of that knowledge with the new interest is in the in the new dashboard you're working on,
Alan Carlson: Right, and so the The other challenge at the same time, we were facing is we were about to hire for new developers that had various backgrounds and skill sets,
Alan Carlson: But they all had minimal experience with with our and shiny specifically right,
Alan Carlson: And so the questions will be you know we're trying to answer immediately was well how do we standardize our workflow so we can minimize your future tech debt with our dashboards that we build,
Alan Carlson: and secondarily, how can I get new hires to understand what we're doing and start building dashboards very quickly right,
Alan Carlson: And so that, when I was researching that problem we learned about what the gold package was,
Alan Carlson: And you know currently the gold package you know, has a very fleshed out github repo it has a published book, you can either purchase or view online,
Alan Carlson: But I looked at it, two years ago it was just this little book down with you know five or so sections that had bare bones concepts and these are still flushing out the process,
Alan Carlson: But the the idea of golem is has stayed the same right they're trying to build modular dashboards with a package based framework and before we go into you know what that means there's going to cover those concepts really quick with a couple slides,
Alan Carlson: So,
Alan Carlson: All shiny Apps at the same thing in common right they use a ui to create a layout that a server to connect data to that layout,
Alan Carlson: And so you build shiny dashboard so there's basically three ways you do so right the first method is the on one approach right, so you can make a very simple dashboard with an APP dot our file,
Alan Carlson: Our codes in one place and it makes simple dashboards when you add more complexity you kind of split the ui and server into their own files,
Alan Carlson: Because that separates the purpose is cleaning right the ui has all the layouts in it the server files all like the code back end in it, and so you know that each of those is referring to it's very specific parts and then eventually lives in like a single folder right,
Alan Carlson: The third method is called modular ization and what this does is you know let's say you want to build a dashboard that serves,
Alan Carlson: Like four different parts of the business right sales product marketing and, like some executive view,
Alan Carlson: If you try and put all that into one server file that's going to be a very large server file which isn't very helpful so modular ization sticks all these sections into their own ui in server for each individual dashboard piece,
Alan Carlson: Additionally, this avoids namespace conflicts that you can sometimes run into with the other methods, but the key point here is that,
Alan Carlson: When you module eyes your dashboards the ui and server become self contained functions that your dashboard will eventually call when it built its dashboard so that's so keep that phrase in mind as we go to the next slide,
Alan Carlson: You know our packages if you've never built in our package you certainly installed one and what a package actually is is it's a bundle of your files data sets unit tests,
Alan Carlson: and individual functions right whether you're using deep flyer or GG plot to you know if you look into their github repos all their functions are tiny little discrete our scripts that are bundled together as a package,
Alan Carlson: Right and so there's that phrase again self contained functions, and so what golem does what it's what it's trying to do, basically,
Alan Carlson: Is it looks at the commonalities between modular ization and package frameworks and other words golem says well if if all my modules are just functions already and a package is just a bundle of functions,
Alan Carlson: Why can I just make my dashboard package and run it and deploy it that way, and he managed to that is packages are very standardized right there are specific folders and directories and locations for files go within and our package,
Alan Carlson: Because of that, though golem has no shortage of creation options right So if you just install golem and try and run with their workflow,
Alan Carlson: Right there's tons of different deployment types, you can do either Rpubs, RStudio connect, docker I believe even do like github pages, at some point,
Alan Carlson: there's different unit tests, you can create either at like the module or the APP level again various ways to import files and different configurations, for your your actual APP and so,
Alan Carlson: When I was testing this out, you know i'm trying to answer those two questions right does it solve those two challenges you're facing,
Alan Carlson: Standardization absolutely right packages like I mentioned, they have to be able to certain way in order to work that they have to have an input folder a man folder,
Alan Carlson: Name spaces descriptions all that standard across every single our package that's ever built,
Alan Carlson: But because of all these complex options it doesn't do a good job of communication to new developers or people that don't have a lot of experience with our shiny and that's by design,
Alan Carlson: And if you look at the first page of the golem book and actually says if you're reading this you have some intermediate advanced level of how shiny works on the back end,
Alan Carlson: And this is trying to explore more possibilities there So what do I need to do, though,
Alan Carlson: So we build traveler to kind of address that complexity, we take away all those options we strip them down to the bare minimum, and say here's these defaults what's wrong with those defaults and you'll be good to go right,
Alan Carlson: be curious about the name so i'm a huge bulk wonder home and goal in itself is,
Alan Carlson: Well, I don't believe the gold package was named after the pokemon dollar, but if i'm taking this you know big complex,
Alan Carlson: package and and making it simpler, the simpler version of gold in the pokemon world's called graveler said that's the name there,
Alan Carlson: And i'm pleased to announce that gravel is available on github currently so you can search either github on or not search get home I observed grammar on github,
Alan Carlson: You can install it with the Dev tools colon colon install underscore github G H Colonel Allen scrambler did a bunch of links in the blog post and whatever,
Alan Carlson: So you can solve yourself there,
Alan Carlson: And so, with that we will switch to,
Alan Carlson: My our screen,
Alan Carlson: For the PowerPoint exits there we go okay so i've already installed, the package of course,
Alan Carlson: When you install you might run into some library dependencies This is my first really public package i'm trying to do so if you run into any of that you know feel free to raise the issue on github,
Alan Carlson: Or you know, let me know at some point, and I can try and work on deals imports correctly when you install it, you should see,
Alan Carlson: Your point seven 5,1 build Santa Monica shiny dashboard frameworks cool so that's step one right, how do we actually start building a manager dashboard right, it sounds pretty complex,
Alan Carlson: The answer is it it's it's not hard to do with with grammar itself, so the first step you'll you'll make a new project either with the button up here or, of course, file new project,
Alan Carlson: You can create you know, a new directory,
Alan Carlson: And you might be thinking well do I go new projects new package shared application none of them because gravity will now have its own,
Alan Carlson: Little wizard type down here at the bottom, there is also the goal and one right, because if you're using gravity, you have to use calm as a back end so you can also look into going for yourself anytime you want, but grabbers what will be focus on focusing on for today,
Alan Carlson: So you'll have just a few simple options here directory name, obviously, RStudio meetup,
Alan Carlson: or just making us part my desktop for now on the package name usually you want those to be no free short and sweet,
Alan Carlson: I,
Alan Carlson: I don't think they run into issues with special characters but I know there's no issues with no special special characters so that's something to keep in mind,
Alan Carlson: And over here you have your display title so in the top left of your dashboard and that's what the user will see is the the dashboard title that's all it's called me up and then, finally, you can put in,
Alan Carlson: We have user names here, you can put in like your full name or whatever just assigned to an author see you know who's running that package right,
Alan Carlson: So don't create a project,
Alan Carlson: takes two seconds to spin up, but then,
Alan Carlson: here's the default grammar layout right, you have this directory that we just made it has all the necessary files that you need to build a package that has the three helpful files to get you started going right so before we get into the first file here the oh and Dev,
Alan Carlson: If you're unfamiliar with packages this description file is where your dependencies lay right so whenever you build a package you have to import other packages that it might rely on right so let's say you know you're trying to build,
Alan Carlson: Some custom package that uses the the deep layer summarize function right, you have to import the deep layer package in order for your package to work right and it with a dashboard you can have a lot of packages, so instead of adding them, you know, one by one, like oops,
Alan Carlson: I can type correctly, instead of imports, you know I can type the reply or did you talk to it's hard to remember all of those right, especially you have new half a dozen libraries to install,
Alan Carlson: instead,
Alan Carlson: Of this one file does are going to have it will it will add dependencies to description into your package itself,
Alan Carlson: So it's just a vector of the dashboards the bare bones dashboards that needs to work on dashboard themes obviously colors everything Dev tools, just in case the player liberdade go Golan pins shiny so on and so forth, I won't go into what all those do so you run the vector,
Alan Carlson: of your environment here then his friends, a simple for loop and attaches those package packages right you'll notice your console it's very colorful right because it will add,
Alan Carlson: The package to import field in description right So if I swing back around to the description file tada it has all of my my imports ready to go,
Alan Carlson: The second part is, we need to add an APP to our file for publishing so RStudio connect when it publishes a dashboard it looks for an APP to our file,
Alan Carlson: Nor, to actually tell it that that file is a dashboard right if I were to just upload this directory as it exists,
Alan Carlson: RStudio with road, air and be like, oh no this is this might be a package I don't publish packages it's not what i'm here for and state create like actual file, I can I can understand right,
Alan Carlson: So you run this line,
Alan Carlson: And you'll notice, my comment that says, you know, be sure to enter one in the console prompt,
Alan Carlson: that's because,
Alan Carlson: golem in order to talk to the rest of the dashboard back end this configurations, it has to make its own little gamble configuration file that's all you need to do is just hit yes for type one excuse me,
Alan Carlson: And then you can read through all this and it basically says use your APP that are file here's the school and configurable file that we have you ever need to edit those it's just an automated file creation for for backend deployment,
Alan Carlson: Then I won't run run this this line of code takes a few minutes, but here at snap we've integrated with RStudios get back content feature,
Alan Carlson: And so what this does it allows you to write what's called a manifest json file, which basically takes a snapshot of all your packages,
Alan Carlson: So that RStudio can actually connect to your github repo find that package snapshot and then publish from from that snapshot,
Alan Carlson: And it's been super useful because, instead of worrying about people individually clicking like the publish button trying to override stuff we can all work from the same github repo single hub file,
Alan Carlson: And the dashboards will update accordingly,
Alan Carlson: So then, after that's done, you can navigate to the rundown Dev folder because your dashboards already ready,
Alan Carlson: Just the second file that open to just navigate to that file, because the description for now, this is the file that you actually use to to run your your dashboard locally right as far as like we're all these lines do,
Alan Carlson: The,
Alan Carlson: prod equals false basically prevents like console messages from printing,
Alan Carlson: or excuse me know true for events cosmetic just from printing so when it's false it allows us to kind of like debug and develop more usually just leave it to false, by default, I never really change it to true,
Alan Carlson: The next two lines are important because it will detach all your lab libraries and remove your environment right and that's important because it needs to,
Alan Carlson: Clean your environment, so that when you run your dashboard locally, you know that's going to work exactly with what's in the dashboard itself right,
Alan Carlson: When I first started working with shiny unit i've run into an issue where it works locally, but not my publish because, for whatever reason, I had some local variable,
Alan Carlson: That we just never in the dashboard click none that lodge was present so works locally, because it's trying to read my local environment,
Alan Carlson: So we wipe the environment, to make sure that the dashboard has exactly what it needs to run,
Alan Carlson: Then, finally,
Alan Carlson: Again, if you're familiar with package development, this is the same thing as the,
Alan Carlson: package build install and restart function down here, so this creates a namespace, which is where all of your exports and imports come from,
Alan Carlson: And then it loads like the meetup package and in actuality you know, once you run this line your package now exists in your environment right it's like do meetup colon colon and current there's only like two functions are exported from it, we can add more,
Alan Carlson: And finally, once that's done you run the APP,
Alan Carlson: And that's it your dashboards already built it has you know the display title that we made it has a working sidebar example has a collapsible sidebar,
Alan Carlson: over here a fun little grab their logo, that you can change the colors you can change as well, but,
Alan Carlson: He struck long as I was explaining it but reality, you can run all those lines and less than a minute right, and you have the entirety of the framework that all you need to do is just add modules to,
Alan Carlson: Right,
Alan Carlson: Which is a good segue into you know how do I create modules actually put content into this dashboard,
Alan Carlson: So if we go back to the open that file there was one line that we forgot at the bottom, which was adding modules so with grammar there's called a level of function,
Alan Carlson: And all you do is you can paste it in your console you're really want to comment out this line, because this is supposed to be once or run once right, so I don't really I just copied the comments and put in my console and then we'll call this,
Alan Carlson: summary or food or you know, whatever you want to call your name of a of your module I recommend keeping them small, because it is going to add some prefixes to this name,
Alan Carlson: So the the short, it is the better, while still being intuitive,
Alan Carlson: So when you run the level up function it's also going to create two files open for you,
Alan Carlson: The MOD underscore name or summary in this case, and then the model underscore summary underscore fct display to our i'll talk about this on a second,
Alan Carlson: But this module is the module code right, this is one section of your dashboard that that you can make so you might be thinking oh great well you put in a box real quick,
Alan Carlson: So you know which equals 12,
Alan Carlson: Probably need an equal sign there,
Alan Carlson: And i'll do title equals,
Alan Carlson: As box today,
Alan Carlson: You think okay cool now I can just read on my dashboard right everything will work,
Alan Carlson: As optimistic thinking, because it will not work,
Alan Carlson: Because your module has yet to actually connect to your actual dashboard layout right and so,
Alan Carlson: Now there's no new sidebar there's no box over here, because you built the module but you haven't connected it to anything so at the bottom of every module for these three lines that you copy into their respective files,
Alan Carlson: I see of your body are your APP server are in your sidebar of our open all those right now all of our files look into the folder itself,
Alan Carlson: To have APP server bonnie and eventually sidebar,
Alan Carlson: So he simply just copy all these in order,
Alan Carlson: It tells you where to add them, so I contact here, adding the module here,
Alan Carlson: For APP server,
Alan Carlson: Here also, the common to connect to a pin board if you use that part of our student connect,
Alan Carlson: And finally give your sidebar item,
Alan Carlson: so terribly you don't need the example there because the example obviously can't connect to anything it's just to show that aside hard working so you just delete this line, or you can contact out either work,
Alan Carlson: This will call the summary,
Alan Carlson: tab name automatically connects to the module itself, and then you can use any kind of the the icon libraries, either for us live icon whatever,
Alan Carlson: You also don't need to save your your files I just did, but as a force of habit which is good, I suppose, but if you have unsealed files whenever you run the Dev file, it will automatically save,
Alan Carlson: Everything in your package before tries to build a you so pay attention to APP server and bonnie up here are these lines of code it saves them and we'll incorporate those changes there, so there we go summary text box array,
Alan Carlson: And now you can simply add, you know as much ui and server functionality, as you want right that's that's outside the purpose of this meeting, because this is a back end not a shiny front end enhancer,
Alan Carlson: So,
Alan Carlson: Where was,
Alan Carlson: trying to figure out the order in which I go through this,
Alan Carlson: Okay, so now we have your module you're probably asking well Okay, if we have the module working what is, what is this fine, what does this fct display file,
Alan Carlson: So in golem their philosophy is you want to abstract away as much as you can from even your module code right so, for example, and you could have,
Alan Carlson: a bunch of different charts or tables in this, but at the moment, your code starts to repeat itself, you want to put that inside of a function,
Alan Carlson: To make this is cleaning compact as possible and so it's a hard concept to explain just verbally, so if i'm going so excuse me i'm going to switch to the actual graveler package because inside of it, there is an example dashboards flushed out called God,
Alan Carlson: itself has its own little modules right so i'll show you what it looks like by default,
Alan Carlson: set my working directory,
Alan Carlson: and
Alan Carlson: that's the default example you can also run this yourself with, I believe,
Alan Carlson: What is it traveler,
Alan Carlson: And you did example as well, with no parameters in it,
Alan Carlson: But so in this first tab you know you notice that there are four graphs here right representing ants ants comscore time so,
Alan Carlson: With a couple GG plot lines and whatnot,
Alan Carlson: So how do I build this right, did I write a GD plot code for different times, no, because you know let's say someone tells you, I want to change those dots from a horrendous line green to an actual human visible color,
Alan Carlson: So in my module and here's why you why right, I have just a two by two grid of charts,
Alan Carlson: you'll notice in my plot lee's renders I have my own custom function here,
Alan Carlson: So my data set and it pipes into a function and that's what this fct display files for its to put all of your functions into one place, so that if you need to edit parts your dashboard you'll need to edit like one piece of the code right where it's duplicated,
Alan Carlson: So in this case let's say I want to change it back to orange,
Alan Carlson: Now I can save this rerun the dashboard and it should work just fine,
Alan Carlson: There you go all for graphs update with the new orange color This applies to any you know GG plot option or data table option or,
Alan Carlson: Whatever functionality, you have in your data and the other advantage to adding functions to your fct file is everyone's favorite documentation right,
Alan Carlson: dashboards and their functionalities at this level, can become incredibly complex and so it's always good to have functionality or excuse me functions,
Alan Carlson: And documentation for those functions, so that yourself or other people reading your dashboard code six months down the road will understand you know what this code is actually trying to do,
Alan Carlson: And the other benefit is, if you recall, if we run these lines,
Alan Carlson: I should be able to export from my package and look at that there's my customer function guess what happens by puts the question mark in front of it,
Alan Carlson: It builds the actual help documentation per oxygen documentation for code, so all of this workflow with golem and whatnot is trying to help you standardize your your package development standards dashboard development as you create documentation for for packages down the road,
Alan Carlson: Finally, before we get into a little more customization,
Alan Carlson: There is the final file that we had open, which was oh to deploy,
Alan Carlson: So when oh to deploy does is when you publish your dashboards on our so you connect they,
Alan Carlson: break for good reason, because they need to have different environment variables to connect either to like database credentials, or if you're using pins you type your API key in there somewhere,
Alan Carlson: And RStudio but by design you can't accept these beforehand right, so you have to publish them and add them after the fact, so this does,
Alan Carlson: It does a programmatic right, you can go in and add your environment variables you're by yourself, by hand by adding the name and the value what this does is it uses the CONNECT API library, which I believe is still in development mode so it's not a grand package yet,
Alan Carlson: Well, you can load this you can load your custom URLs ours will be snap finance whatever whatever URL and then you can connect to the server,
Alan Carlson: Which is you set the server variables you connect to the server, then you find the the ID for that piece of content you're deploying,
Alan Carlson: You can paste that whatever and then you can add the environment, right here, right, so this example i'm finding whatever I just published,
Alan Carlson: I get the environment for that published content and I add a new variable called key and then I set my own right setting equal to whatever my API key is personally,
Alan Carlson: So that saves us a lot of time with deploying stuff in RStudio connect,
Alan Carlson: But I imagine you probably asked yourself with some point well this is great, but I don't want this like Brown and Gray dashboard right, I have, I have very cool purple or blue or yellow business right, I want to brand my own dashboards,
Alan Carlson: So if you go into this theme file right here, the very bottom,
Alan Carlson: that's where you can just set your colors so there's three colors you can do primary accent secondary,
Alan Carlson: You can emit these entirely and just trying to you know customize everything a line by line I don't feel like you need to do that, but be my guest, so I just changes colors to,
Alan Carlson: me know so many hex codes will go that rent black,
Alan Carlson: My dashboard again,
Alan Carlson: It will update with these colors it's my primary is dark red this accent is bright red and then there's just like black bar on the left for this sidebar option here,
Alan Carlson: Again there's more customized ability, you can do, but that's what i've been sufficient for the average user is those three colors,
Alan Carlson: As well as the the logo you don't see you have your own custom logo to do,
Alan Carlson: Just like in a standard shiny APP all of the external assets are in the end, staff dub dub dub folder so you just add your logo here and replace the the header,
Alan Carlson: value with the new file path so here's the file exists that if I go into the header back in the folder,
Alan Carlson: here's that file path is so I just replace this with you know your logo,
Alan Carlson: svg P amp G jpg whatever,
Alan Carlson: You can also attach the URLs so when we ever we publish content, the the title and the logo will link back to our content page, so instead of like hitting the back button,
Alan Carlson: or anything like that they can just click right click the title open a new tab back to the content, page, by default, it just goes to RStudios products page,
Alan Carlson: So you can change those however you want,
Alan Carlson: But with that I believe that's it for like the graveler dashboard workflow itself again i'm not going to go into you know, creating ui elements or,
Alan Carlson: pin calls or anything like that, because that's it, you can restart there's plenty of better documentation that I could ever make out there for that,
Alan Carlson: So we'll switch back to the PowerPoint really quick,
Alan Carlson: The part where it goes back here so potential enhancements you know if if some of you've worked with this kind of your dashboard thing or a customization before you might have,
Alan Carlson: thought of these ideas already so as far as you know, with any code there's always improvements be mean here's what i've thought for the travel package immediately,
Alan Carlson: So as of like shiny 1,5 there's a new method of calling modules so instead of the actual call module function there's I think module server does what it does, it has a simple simple syntax and understanding, so be cool if I could convert it to that,
Alan Carlson: Obviously the dashboard package, and you have those colors like customization but bs lives but integrated with shiny already, and so you can,
Alan Carlson: use that more intuitively and creating cleaner colors and layouts you know the time when I build this none of these things exist in two years ago,
Alan Carlson: And finally, your packages live on testing right, the more complex your dashboard is the more points of breakage you're creating itself, and so, if we can somehow you know connect unit tests,
Alan Carlson: To be put on these like dashboard packages that'd be great it's just one of those areas that,
Alan Carlson: Again I don't really have a fundamental understanding of unit testing, and so I have trouble automating something I don't really know the ins and outs of but in general you'll spend less time debugging all of your parameters code,
Alan Carlson: But with that you know that's all I had to talk about like from a high level, so I mean feel free to ask questions about like the the package itself, you know the back end how it's doing its things,
Alan Carlson: But in general traveler allows like our new developers to you know start building dashboards right away, we have about like a two week,
Alan Carlson: On mourning period,
Alan Carlson: With you know the intermediate sequel and our training and then in house training as well, and after the end of two weeks we give them a week to build the first grabber dashboard that workflow,
Alan Carlson: And so I mean the turnaround of 15 business days you have people building the some of the best and shiny Apps you can only guess, not the best idea, you can make,
Alan Carlson: Robust shiny Apps very quickly so huge shout out to RStudio as well, I mean the in itself was a game changer for us, but the ability to integrate with with github and package manager and,
Alan Carlson: You know, being able to install our custom packages like rather to use and publish our workflows gotten a lot more simple, a lot more standardized,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thank you so much Ellen I always say we're all clapping even though you can't hear us if we can use her clapping mo geez here in zoom,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But thank you so much for your presentation and also want to put a shout out for a great blog post that Alan recently wrote as well, which walks through this too, and includes a lot of great links to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Let me put that into the chat right here,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But just a reminder to that you can raise your hand on here to ask questions, and I can just call on you, or you can use slideshow tool to ask questions anonymously as well,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): But I see, there is one over on slider so let me go to that first,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): One was have you worked with the golem team and on the package,
Alan Carlson: Ah, no there, I have not, I believe I met,
Alan Carlson: One of the authors at RStudio conference a couple years ago, so I wanted to get like his thoughts and you're like what Golan was, but it was a very small conversation and and I haven't worked with them at all that'd be cool, though, but,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Definitely, I see john also put a question to slide oh and john feel free to jump in if you want to ask a question live to,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): or add context because i'll i'll read it first but is, are there any plans to include any simple goolies in the package, either to link modules to other files and or to diagram magically show modules and how they fit,
Alan Carlson: Yes, so we've thought about that in the past,
Alan Carlson: def definitely there's room for module templates so I mean you can just like I wrote box with her a you can just put this as a default, so it can make kinda like these little template layouts,
Alan Carlson: it's just not something i've had time to work on in the past, but that is an idea we've had as far as the second half of the question,
Alan Carlson: As you can you read again Rachel this side, make sure right,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Yes, one, second, and it was,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): So of course plans to make it simple ui in the package, either to link modules to other files or to show modules and how they fit together,
Alan Carlson: Yes, the diagram thing so,
Alan Carlson: I don't really know how to do that from like the package programmatic perspective i've done it personally just making like you, like a readme file for a project i'll make just a quick little diagram with your diagram are or,
Alan Carlson: You know the various various,
Alan Carlson: flow chart packages, so if there's a way you can do it programmatically that that would be awesome I do know I I always forget what the code is but there's something like the US, this package or the RS connect package, where it's like,
Alan Carlson: Create manual I know but whenever you search a package on crane it has like the big PDF right where it links to all the functions and then kind of displays all that you can actually build one of those,
Alan Carlson: For your dashboard and all of its functions with just one line of code right, so all you would have to do is wash my,
Alan Carlson: clothes, the wrong file,
Alan Carlson: Once you you'll go this far, in your run def films you actually have access to your,
Alan Carlson: That happens every now and then I think just a version of my our thing anyways once you get this far, in your package, and so you can export everything you can create that PDF somehow I just I always forget to do it, but that's that's what I have for that question,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): awesome thanks Alan I see mj just asked in the chat can we get this recording and, yes, I will share it up to the RStudio YouTube,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): As well as on the meetup page and linkedin and Twitter anywhere that I mentioned the meetup as well, but I did just put the playlist of all meetup recordings there in the chat too,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And again, I would love to hear from you all to if you want to jump in and ask questions feel free to just raise your hand on zoom or I can even take unmuted yourself as raising your hand,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): No it's hard, sometimes in these,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Virtual rooms, but I like to imagine we're all there in person together Robbie AC you just put a question into the chat if you want to to jump in,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): And that is what's your opinion on shiny mobile,
Alan Carlson: Ah yes,
Alan Carlson: So we looked into shiny mobile once upon a time,
Alan Carlson: And as cool as it was, it was just such a new framework to do that, we had already pretty much doubled down on like Goldman graveler and this method of building,
Alan Carlson: So we didn't find a ton of value, back then, in trying to also learn shiny mobile that's slightly changed because with the growth of our business, now we have more,
Alan Carlson: more focused on like our external sales team that's out in the in the country, and so they premiered welcome mobile devices and so that's something we're currently trying to revisit but it's still the early stages of planning, so I don't really have much more info that,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Thanks Alan i'm going to actually stop the recording so people feel comfortable jumping into their questions, but for the recording Thank you all for watching, so let me,
Rachael Dempsey (she/her): Let me stop that,